this is the closest I can come to saying  what I've learned I spent all my time  staring in one direction and I missed it  the most important moments were just in  the edges  [Music]  hi I'm Monica mr. Cho let's see your  driver's license  why you get a lot of strange woman  pretending to be maids did you bathe  this whole seriously 9 a.m. and he's  already picturing  anybody wanna muddy Mary come inside and  get a cup don't you think you should  just slow down you drink like a fish  because I see me and him Oh big boy  I had a friend if you look like you how  was your first day at school  yeah  [Music]  hahaha you can't just leave them out  here  [Music]  I can't believe this who died do not say  like that all the days to run down  alcohol  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  Jr pork actually been looking for you  Bakri  [Music]  [Applause]  you can see my father stood before me  [Music]  I think we're all bastards and Saints  just depends on the day  you